2+3=9違うよねこんにちははじめしゃ
ちょーですはいあの
愚痴というか普通にやばいでしょっていう
話でございます今日あることはもう
ちょっとなんか
怒りというより恐怖恐怖の方が増してるん
ですけどもちょっとあの最近あったことを
お話しさせていただきたいと思いますもう
動画のタイトルにある通りですねあのマジ
で命の危険を感じたというかああ俺これ
多分
死んだなもう殺されるなっていう
感じのことが起きましたタクシーに乗っ
てる時の話ですはい口で言ってても
なかなか伝わらないと思うので結構完全
再現に近いレベルで本当にあったことを
ちょっと再現VTRにしてみましたので
まずはそちらをご覧くださいどうぞ
[音楽]
お願いします
ご乗車ありがとうございますお客様どちら
まで行かれますかあじゃあ六本木の方まで
お願いしますはいかしこまりましたでは
シートベルトの方よろしくお願い致します
はいいたしますはーい
[音楽]
今
寝てた
やけど全然普通に運転してるしな
[音楽]
おまた信号だ
赤になった
運転はうまいな
あー
寝てるねこの人
えちょっと
マジか
動かないし
向かっちゃった
ギリギリで気づいた
いやちょっともう怖いなこれ事故られたら
死ぬぞ俺
あまた信号係になった
[音楽]
うわーもうこれ絶対ダメだこの人もうマジ
で寝てるもう絶対寝てるあー鬼だったあー
起きる気配がないうわこれもう本当にもう
やばい俺死ぬ死ぬ死ぬ死ぬ死ぬ死ぬなんか
残っておきたし
あっそこ左でお願いしますはいあ左ハイ
確かめました
うわめっちゃ元気やん
返事だけめっちゃ元気やんこの人
はい
居眠り運転ですこれ場合眠り運転ですよね
ちょっとあの運転中まで寝てるかどうか
わかんなかったんですけどその今わかん
ないじゃんマスクつけてるし僕もマスク
つけてるし運転手さんもマスクつけてる
からなんかメガネもかけてたしその人表情
もよくわかんなくて運転中どうだったのか
わかんないですけどもう
赤信号で停止してる時にも完全に
マジでもう
持ってないからもう冗談だけど本当にもう
赤信号になった瞬間もう
本当にもういきなり額みたいなぐとぐと
するいやそのダメですよもちろんダメです
うとうとするのもダメですけども歌うと
するとかじゃなくてもいきなり
バーンってもう寝ててその場で赤信号待ち
で3回寝てるんですよ3回心房3回やって
3回とマジで寝てましたもう絶対ドライブ
レコーダーで見直したいぐらいでも怖いし
ちょっと予定があって結構急いでたしまあ
ちょっとどうするのが正解だったんだろう
か
運転手さんがなんか機嫌悪いとかも
話してる感じで眠そうだなとかなんか
明らかに体調悪そうだったら僕もなんか
大丈夫ですかって声かけやすかったんです
けどなんか左曲がってくださいみたいに声
をかけたらあはい左ですね
みたいなもうめっちゃ元気なんですよだ
からさもうこうなっててもさ下で何か見
てるかもしんないじゃんもちろん何も
なかったんですけど何か意味があってこう
なってたのかもしんないしマスクメガネで
何もわかんないからこれがちょっとその
まだその時の俺からすると寝てるかどうか
判断つかなくてまあ明らかに後ろから
クラクション鳴らされてる時点で絶対寝て
ますけど絶対寝てるね100%に出てます
俺もう怖すぎて車のナンバー写真撮ました
からねもうもう
怖くてもう手振れしてるよごめんなさい
ちょっとあのパニクってたのと怖くてなん
か
喋れなかったです正直なんかさもう
もちろんダメなことは分かってるんです
けども1回ぐらいだったら100歩譲って
まああってなるんすよ
赤信号では運転士さんあ
運転手さんがちょっと眠そうにしてる疲れ
てるんだろうな大丈夫かなって分かるんだ
けど3回連続で
寝られてみてもう
声出なくなっちゃうから普通にあこの人
たぶん寝ながらずっと運転してんだみたい
ないや言えばよかったなもうクラクション
鳴らされた時点でもうおかしいもんな
体現VTRだとちょっと分かりづらかった
と思うんですけど
普通に青になってから10秒止まってたり
するんですよそれ確かなんかもう
道路的に良くなかったんすよねなんだっけ
発信不能だってな俺車の免許の実技試験で
赤信号が青になってまた無くてで発進不能
っていうので限定されて落とされたことが
あるから赤から青になってしばらく進ま
ないんだ確かダメなことなんだよね普通に
青信号で動かないとダメだった気がします
ちょっとねーちょっとねなんか怒りとと
いうかな普通にしっかりしてくれやとは
思いますけどなんかね震えたねなんか今
までいろんなタクシーの運転手さんいます
ねもちろんなんか
機嫌悪い運転手さんもいましたし基本的に
はほんといい人ばっかりだし最近俺をさ
日本縦断の旅に連れてってくれたタクシー
の運転手さんもすごいいい人だったし素敵
なタクシーの運転手さんはたくさんいます
けど中にはほんと変わった人もいてもう
機嫌悪い運転手さんだったりなんか
ちょっとした距離だったらもう舌打ちさ
れる運転手さんもいたしもうめちゃくちゃ
運転荒くてえもうなんか
赤ちゃんの運転もガンダムとブレーキを
繰り返すみたいなそれも多分腕に自信が
あるからやってたのかもしんないですけど
本当色んなタクシーの運転手さんに
東京でお仕事たくさんするようになってて
やってきたんですけどこんなになんか
はっきりとしたなんか
明確な
死というかなんか寝てる人に運転を任せ
てる恐怖それはなんか当たり前のように
信号3回分続けるっていう人がいることに
すごい
驚きというかうわやべえなって思いました
俺はなんとかいきねってたけどさあの運転
車なんかまた別のお客さんを乗せてまた
そんな中眠今から運転してるとさもう
事故るじゃん絶対ちょっと本当にこの運転
手さんだけに関わらずタクシーだけの話で
はないですけどちょっと運転
ほんとに今日つけないとな自分持って
改めて思いましたしいやでもやっぱタク
シーってお金貰ってるからさあなんかその
人に知らない人にお金を払ってみよう
預けて運転してもらってるからちょっと
より一層気をつけて欲しかったなとは思い
ましたしなんか
タクシーだとしても俺はもう安心できない
なと思ってしまってもうタクシーで寝れ
なくなっちゃったかもしんないなぁまぁ
寝るけど寝るけど本当にちょっと怖かった
なっていう話ですごめんちょっと愚痴
っぽくなりましたけどマジでね俺もう死ん
だって思ったこの人に殺されんだって思っ
て本当に目的地まで向かいましたマジで
あのタクシーのさ社内のドラレコ見たいも
その運転手段の挙動がもう誰がどう見ても
絶対寝てるんで俺の思い違いではないのは
かなり自信ありますだって信号3回動けて
ないもんお仕事でお疲れなのは分かります
けどもあの運転中はどうか
許して欲しいと思います今度からちょっと
無神経に起きてますかって声をかけて
みようちょっと本当にもう怖いマジで1
回死んだと思ってます
[音楽]